The first one I'd like to talk about is the lone ranger.
This is where you are an early adopter of Power BI,
and possibly the only one at your organization.
In this situation, your stakeholders will be your report consumers,
which might be clients, company leadership,
or simply your team if the work you do is heavily data-driven.
Your allies need to be anyone who holds the keys to data.
That might be someone in IT, for example,
who knows where to find the data available through SQL,
Access databases, SharePoint lists, etc.
This is someone you want to be friend, bring donuts to,
generally maintain a strong mutual positive relationship with,
they can help you a lot.
Your key to the data kingdom in my experience,
is the phrase read-only access.
The person who controls access to the data might be rightly
concerned about limiting those who can edit and intentionally,
or unintentionally, corrupt the data.
So you're far more likely to get access to
the data if you make it clear that you only need to read,
not write the data.
Your key challenge might be getting the foundation right without
an in-house mentor or team to help you troubleshoot in Power BI when you get stuck.
As an early adopter,
you are probably passionate about what could be
and how this technology can drive improvements in your own work,
your team, maybe the company as a whole.
All that said, this is one of those times when you need to go slow,
so you can go fast later on.
Focus on getting those key principles right first,
so you don't shoot yourself in the foot down the line as your data model scale.
On the flip side, your key opportunity is to make
those positive impact interactive data analytic tools so that Power BI can
have that positive impact on decision-making and comprehension of large data-sets,
potentially across your entire company.